salut vous vous êtes peut-être posé la
question tiens il y a une allocution de
notre président est-ce que Fabien licard
va en faire une analyse oui non
évidemment avertissement de début de
vidéo si vous ne connaissez pas mon
travail c'est très important de
l'écouter l'analyse que je vais faire ne
concerne que moi je suis pas pro Macron
je ne suis pas antimacron je vais
utiliser des outils qui viennent de
plein de domaines y compris des espèces
de pseudosciences de l'interprétation
comportementale c'est un exercice de
style mais ça vaut pas plus qu'une
discussion de comptoir n'enlevez pas cet
avertissement si vous utilisez des
passages de cette vidéo Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs
bienvenue elle est un peu amusante la
tête de Gabriel àal quand le président
Macron dit Monsieur le Premier Ministre
parce que ça me rappelle certains bisage
qu'on a vu chez François Hollande quand
on l'appelait monsieur le Président il y
a un petit côté ah bon ah oui ah
d'accord blag à part lui a le visage
très fermé parce que là il joue sa
crédibilité là pour le moment après
l'allongement du congé paternité je
crois profondément que la mise en en
place d'un nouveau congé de
naissance sera un élément utile dans une
une telle stratégie congé de naissance
qui viendra remplacer le congé parentale
actuel grand plan de lutte contre ce
fléo sera engagé pour permettre
justement ce réarmement démographique le
le petit baffouillement il a un intérêt
en tout cas assez pour qu'on s'arrête
dessus sera un élément utile dans une
une telle stratégie on baffouille qu' on
n'est pas sûr de ce qu'on dit ou quand
on stresse de ce qu'on dit je pense
qu'il sait que là c'est un gros enjeu et
que ça va beaucoup faire parler et que
c'est sûrement pour ça j'interprète
aussi un petit peu le fond qu'ils ont
utilisé toute la sémantique de la guerre
de l'armement et cetera grand plan de
lutte contre ce fléo sera engagé pour
permettre justement ce réarmement
démographique c'est un combat et un
combat on peut pas se défider en fait
c'est ça qui est intéressant les
spécialistes de la rhétorique vous
expliqueront ça sûrement mieux que moi
mais du coup ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'il est juste sabonné comme on dit au
moment de le prononcer ça veut dire que
même pour lui c'est pas naturel d'en
parler comme ça et que il l'a pas encore
complètement intégré et surtout il sera
plus court que le congé parental actuel
qui peut parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et
qui éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché
du travail là c'est dans les intonations
et cette intonation là est quand même
une forme de manipulation on ne peut pas
être contre puisqu'il utilise des
ination puisque nanana alors que nanana
et en fait on s'en fiche des mots qui y
a à l'intérieur le nanana c'est c'est
une évidence c'est une évidence en plus
malheureuse et heureusement
qu'aujourd'hui on répare ça parce que
sement que le fond il y a des choses qui
sont vraies dans ce qui sont dit là mais
en réalité c'est pas vrai dans 100 % des
cas donc c'est un peu fallacieux
d'utiliser cette intonation de voix pour
argumenter de cette mesure de vous
encourage à ne formuler qu'une seule
question par prise de parole question
courte s'il vous plaît et de la même
manière monsieur le Président nous
savons pouvoir compter sur la concision
de vos
réponses riez pas quand même cette
attitude là elle montre à quel point là
il risque pas grand-chose c'est-à-dire
il est sur son territoire avec ses
règles du jeu avec ses grands alliés ou
en tout cas des personnes qui lu sont
loyales autour de lui c'est un exercice
un peu bah ça se voit maintenant quoi un
peu marrant il craint pas grand-chose en
fait à faire ce qu'il fait ici pense
qu'on l'a rarement vu autant détendu en
fait sur une prise de parole quand je
regarde ces 5 dernières années le SMIC a
augmenté de 20 % 20 % les smicars ont
gagné le pouvoir d'achat un travailleur
qui est au SMIC à temps complet mais
donc on peut dire que notre ministre de
la santé c'est bien ça l hein c'esté
travail Santé Travail solidarité là on a
ce petit mouvement alors qui est parfait
donc on a l'étonnement ça vous l'avez vu
en même temps que moi en même temps la
tête qui tourne de je refuse un petit
peu cette information on n pas eu le
mouvement de recul du siège elle sait se
contenir elle est clairement pas aligné
avec ce qu' vient de dire ok j'étais en
train de de ticker aussi au point qu'on
vient d'en parler là avec loï qui est
derrière der la caméra mais en fait
c'est il y a une ambigué entre le
salaire qui a augmenté de X % et le
pouvoir d'achat qui prend en compte
l'inflation et cetera qui a augmenté de
X %. c'est pour ça que c'est pas clair
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'altique
il a 95 % des absences qui sont comblés
on mais on arrive à mettre un prof
devant les élèves le ressenti sur le
terrain n'était pas le même pourquoi
parce qu'on ne faisait pas remonter au
National les absences de court terme on
ne les mesurait même pas donc on a
ouvert le capot et on est allé regarder
le remplacement de court terme et on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait une dizaine
de millions d'heures chaque année qui
étit perdu c'est fou et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il a le visage encore si
étonné le même étonnement sur le visage
que le jour où on lui a dit ça parce que
c'est quand même fou que les gens
fassent pas remonter l'information quand
même heureusement Emmanuel Macron le
mécano donc on a ouvert le capot ouvert
le capot bon le la surprise
est un peu là surjouer c'était pas
nécessaire professeur absent parce qu'il
avait une formation on a complètement
repensé le système et donc là on est en
train de s'organiser on a commencé
deuxième chose on utilisait si je puis
dire on gaspillait du temps de
professeur pour surveiller les examens
on réorganise ça bon souvenez-vous je
vous en ai déjà parlé dans dans les
vidéos et même en spectacle j'en parle
d'ailleurs quand il sait pas quoi dire
il passe au compte mais en même temps
c'est pas bête he parce que ça structure
la pensée on a l'impression que la
personne elle sait où elle veut aller ça
évite de bugger en fait tout en tout en
parlant mais c'est toujours marrant de
le voir faire on a un mouvement
sarkoszien à la fin de cette
conversation regarde pour surveiller les
examens on réorganise ça là on a on a
vraiment avec un petit deep fake on a
Nicolas Sarkozi dans le mouvement et
presque dans l'intonation ça c'est on
l'avait on l'avait déjà vu dans la
dernière analyse est-ce que du coup tous
ces mouvements parasites est-ce qu'il
viennent du stress de la fonction je
commence à me demander alors autant
François Hollande n'avait pas ça du tout
autant Emmanuel Macron l'avait pas au
début et ça fait un an que je constate
que il a de plus en plus de gestuel
qu'on avait chez chez Nicolas Sarkozi et
et dont on se moquait un petit peu en
mant les épaules qui bougent bah il l'
aussi hein j'ai pas très bien compris si
les Français allaient voir leur
électricité augmenter de 10 % ou pas
tout à l'heure quand vous avez répondu à
la question de mon collègue de TEF parce
qu'il l'a pas formulé comme ça mais je
peux vous dire que je me substituerai
pas au gouvernement pour faire pour
faire les annonces précises mais ce que
je disais c'est que l'électricité le
prix va revenir dans la norme mais
surtout il restera quel que soit ce que
le gouvernement annonce dans les
prochains
jours substantiellement inférieur à ce
qui est payé en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie ça faut le regarder aussi la
phrase de conclusion avec la tête qui
dodline elle dodline plus vers le non
que vers le oui parce que là on a une
démonstration de langue de bois c'est
dire que on peut se référer qu'aux
intonations puisque les mots ils sont
creux c'est-à-dire que je vais pas me
substituer mais substantiellement on va
avec un projet
à l'heure de la mondialisation
démocratique devenir acteur de notre
énergie sans il répond à rien c'est pour
ça que dans ces intonations de
conclusion il peut pas s'empêcher de
deliner la tête pour marquer la fin
parce que c'est non c'est juste une
technique de d'évitement et donc là où
ça aurait dû augmenter de plus de 100 %
l'année dernière ça dû augmenter de 25 %
l'électricité et on va continuer d'avoir
un prix d'électricité nettement
inférieur à nos voisins donc la
conclusion pardon je reviens sur du
verbal et on va avoir un prix
d'électricité nettement inférieur à nos
voisins ça ne répond pas du tout à la
question qui était très simple ce qui
veut dire aussi qu'on doit conjurer une
forme de fatalité français qui est qu'on
consomme trop de médecine en même temps
qu'on a une des médecines les plus
socialisées du monde c'est-à-dire où
c'est pas le consommateur qui la paye
mais c'est toujours pareil il y a pas
d'argent magique quand c'est pas le
consommateur qui la paye c'est le
contribuable qui la paye au moment où de
manière sérieuse je vois ce que nos
compatriotes peuvent dépenser pour les
forfaits de téléphonie la vie
quotidienne se dire pardon mais j'ai
envie de faire des analyses de de de
fond plus que de forme aujourd'hui mais
alors ça vient de deux choses ça vient
que blague à part vous trouvez pas que
c'est le film de plus en plus large
qu'on puisse de moins en moins voir les
micro détails qu'il a sur le visage et
le comportement bon c'est c'est c'est
pas lié à moi c'est sûr mais c'est
embêtant pour le truc quoi que c'est pas
lié à moi c'est c'est c'est pas lié à
moi c'est sûr mais c'est embêtant pour
le truc et il y a beaucoup aussi de
plans qui reviennent sur le public donc
ah j'arrive pas à voir en en permanence
par contre justifier du nickel en disant
quand je vois que les gens se font
plaisir et mènent une vie de luxe en
ayant un téléphone et dans la vie
quotidienne ils se font des petits
plaisirs je me dis bah alors
oh c'est non c'est trop ça n'a rien à
voir la vie quotidienne et puis j'ai vu
passer un tweet de de Xavier Nil il a
repris ce passage là et et il a mis ça
se voit qu'il a pas un forfait frie lui
ça vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont des forfaits à 2 € et tout va bien
passer de 50 centimes à 1 € pour un
paquet de pour un paquet ok pardon pour
un
médicament une boîte de médicament j'ai
pas le sentiment qu'on fait un crime
terrible c'est pour nos compatriotes qui
ont des affection de longue durée
c'est-à-dire des maladies qui supposent
des prescriptions régulières eux faut
continuer de les protéger et eux ils
sont protégés parce qu'on a mis un
plafond c'est qu'il sont pas plus de 50
€ par an ça faut le garder donc on va
faire quelque chose de juste je crois
c'est marrant dans dans dans les
intonations et dans les gestuels comme
il veut jouer la sympathie naturelle on
l'a vu dans d'autres positions surtout
dans les alloptions vraiment
présidentielles qui sont faites à
l'Élysée là on voit l'envie de donner un
sentiment de bah de sincérité
d'honnetteté de je discute avec vous je
suis pas en train de de forcer des
traits ou je suis pas en train d'essayer
de convaincre alors que si tout exercice
de prise de parole du gouvernement et
aussi d'essayer de convaincre de quelque
chose et quand on a un limite emoji en
fait qui nous fait je crois je crois
pourquoi on nous reprocherit ça c'est
quand même évident je crois vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ça ça envoie un
sentiment où on n'est pas en train de
faire des débats argumentatif avec
quelqu'un qui peut expliquer
rationnellement le les diverses
nécessités parce que il y a toujours
plusieurs raison en fait à une prise de
décision j'essaie de qualifier les
émeutes qu'on a eu l'été dernier d'abord
je vis dire que ces émeutes elles ont eu
j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal à me
dire que la position d'Ema actuellement
n'est pas conscientisée le les conseill
mais surtout Emmanuel Macron lui-même
c'est très bien qu'il y a des gens qui
vont regarder et qui interprètent voilà
je vous a
dit c'est très bien et là d'avoir le
point comme ça avec l'autre point
l'impression qu'il va faire le tour de
magie des mains qui se transperscent
l'une l'autre quand quand quand quand il
fait ça en serrant c'est pas une
position agréable faites-le c'est pas
une position naturelle non plus ça fait
un peu mal ça peut être interprété par
des gens comme moi mais par tout le
monde c'est quand même un peu bizarre de
vouloir faire de l'Union et en même
temps du retien force comme s'il y a
quelque chose qui' qui t'énervait sans
en avoir conscience je je sais pas ce
qu'il voudrait envoyer là parce que
c'est pas du tout raccord avec son
expression faciale d'ailleurs mais là il
y a quelque chose d'un peu étrange en
face d'elle une réponse implacable de
l'État ah c'est le implacable le
implacable correspond en fait à ce
mouvement alors est-ce que c'est
conscient est-ce que c'est pas conscient
mais c'est l'État qui vient répondre à
cette problématique et qui ne lâchera
rien si c'est pas conscient bah ça
devrait être évité si c'est conscient c
une mauvaise idée maintenant j'essaie de
voir ce qu'il y a parce qu'on a voulu
tout de suite dire c'est un problème
d'immigration c'est un problème de ceci
de cela d'abord elles sont intervenues
fin
juin c'était beaucoup de très jeunes qui
étaient dans les rues c'était des jeunes
qui ont pas la chance d'avoir des
familles qui les emmènent à la mer à la
montagne qui justement ont pas assez
accès à la culture au
sport il s'ennuy alors là on est sur un
billet de corrélation illusoire c'est un
billet cognitif du cerveau qui est servi
je pense avec intention en tout cas je
l'espère oui alors on peut on peut
comparer très volontairement s'ils
avaient accès à de la culture ou à des
vacances et en faire la comparaison avec
le fait qu'ils aient fait des émeutes on
peut faire la même chose avec le fait
que je ne porortais plus de pull en
cette période ce qui voudrait dire que
quand je porte plus de pull il y a plus
d'émeut donc il faudrait que je porte
plus de pull non ça c'est c'est c'est
mon analyse c'est une analyse de
comptoir là c'est une discussion de
comptoir qui fait des jeunes sans
activité très jeunes et ensuite les
écrans ont eu un rôle très important
qu'on avait jamais vu c'est-à-dire en
quelques minutes on voyait des centaines
d'actions se déployer des rendez-vous
donnés sur tel ou tel je ferai pas de
stigmatisation réseau social par l'écran
et il y a eu une forme de mimétisme qui
a conduit à un embrasement totalement
déraisonné ça je trouve ça bien qu'il
est conscience de en fait du danger des
écrans et des réseaux sociaux et du
pouvoir du mémétisme par l'écran après
je pense aussi qu'il connaissait un
petit peu la stratégie puisque ça a été
l'un des premiers à se mettre S TikTok
puisqu'il a fait des vidéos avec des
youtubeurs puisqu'il a beaucoup utilisé
les réseaux sociaux pour ses campagnes
et pour appuyer ses messages donc par
contre j'espère qu'il n'en est pas
étonné voilà mais c'est bien qu'il estit
conscience que il y a pas que lui qui
avait remarqué que que les réseaux
sociaux et les vidéos avaient un pouvoir
parce que il le sait depuis très
longtemps il faut lu apporter mais c'est
pas une réponse aux émeutes est-ce que
la réponse cétait plus de policier non
on a recréé on avait recréé déjà et dans
ces villes elles avaient toutes plus de
policiers que 2 ans avant toutes et
estce que la réponse c'était plus
d'investissement politique de la ville
ce que me disait disait de l'autre côté
c'est pas vrai donc les réponses faciles
de gauche et de droite classique que
j'ai vu selon les orientations des après
tout faux réponse plus compliquée et
donc la réponse c'est de se dire 1 on
doit réengager avec les familles il y a
une chose qui est sûre c'est que
Emmanuel Macron en tant que président de
la République avec de l'expérience sait
contrôler son corps et et le message non
verbaux qui va envoyer et on le voit
très bien là et ça a été un peu le cas
là durant tout plan de de de la prise de
parole il sait se montrer surexcité donc
il sautille sur son siège là vous pouvez
le voir à l'image li vous fait voir
quand il satille de tous les côtés au
point même de se rasseoir on sait pas
s'il va se lever ou si s'il va se
rasseoir ça c'est quand il veut
convaincre quand il veut envoyer le
message de son engagement émotionnel et
ça rentre comme ça après en rupture
quand il reprend sa position
présidentielle des mesures et des
solutions et et et des points qui qui
vont trouver une solution bienent où là
il se restabilise et où il dit et c'est
intéressant parce que si on regarde
comme ça d'un œil inattentif on peut se
laisser embarquer en fait par l'énergie
déployée et après comprendre avec
l'intonation et le contrôle du corps que
ça maintenant c'est comme ça et que
c'est important et surtout que c'est la
seule solution d'accompagner certaines
familles 60 % de ces jeunes venent de
famille monoparentale le fait de se
pencher comme ça vers l'avant avec cette
intonation c'est le S sentiment de
confidence je vais vous faire une
confidence et donc là là on oublie tout
ce qu'on est en train de faire là là
c'est de vous à moi vous vous rendez
compte quand même et je reprends ma
position derrière si on s'attaque pas
pied à pied à l'incohérence de leur
programme les gens se disent disent des
trucs faciles l'opposition c'est
beaucoup plus facile que le gouvernement
donc faut aller au réel sur ce qu'il
propose ah ben pour une fois je trouve
que cette phrase
elle est vraie alors comme j'ai tendance
à faire des analyses on a l'impression
que je suis anti tout et bien ça je dis
oui je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de rentrer en opposition que
d'être aux place de gouvernement cette
phrase et cette opinion je l'applique
pour tous les gouvernements que j'ai
connu depuis ma naissance en 82 je pense
que c'est plus facile en fait de
d'opposer que que que de gouverner mais
je rajouterai quand même c'est plus
facile de choisir ces mots ces éléments
de langage et les représentations
visuelles ou d'intonation qu'on veut
donner que d'être sincère cérémonie de
remise des dipl diplôme uniforme est-ce
que ce sont pas des vieux débats je vois
tous nos jeunes qui regardent les séries
télévisées où il y a Cesis de diplôme il
trouent ça super je vois qu'on retrouve
des rites quand la République perd ses
rites d'autres rites sont inventés moi
je crois pas du tout que le symbolique
soit vieux jeu je crois pas du je vais
vous dire la position les intonations et
tout là c'est très intéressant alors
aussi parce que c'est c'est un petit peu
dans la durée mais là pour le coup
Emmanuel Macron redevient plus naturel
il croise les bras le menton levé bien
adossé dans son siège en réalité en
faisant ça il il se met en fait à être
l'orateur sur la place publique donc là
il va déclamer pour parler aux gens mais
aussi pour s'entendre lui-même déclamer
et toute la position est comme ça il est
pas en train de convaincre comme tout à
l'heure il est en train de philosopher
donc on va avoir la pensée d'Emmanuel
Macron je je l'expliquis tout à l'heure
en disant ce qui a fait notre pays c'est
l'ordre et le progrès pourut donner des
rendez-vous des Caps de passage la fin
du primaire le brevet des collèges ça
c'est ce sont des débuts de sourire de
satisfaction alors de satisfaction en
fait c'est purement cérébral et c'est
pour ça qu'on voit ce ce ce début de de
joie et de sourire c'est-à-dire que il
vient d'avoir son éclair de génie c'est
pas quelque chose qui avait été préparé
là pour le coup il vient de trouver
comment on résolvait le c-etête et il
est très fier de sa solution et de la
donner croyez-moi parce que si on passe
dans la vie comme ça comme entre des
courants tout le monde est perdu et moi
je trouve que
beaucoup de gens sont perdus c'est là où
il a perdu pour le coup lui le fil de
son éclair de genénide d'où le blanc
d'ailleurs qu'il a eu c'est que il il a
il a paumé ce qu'il avait pour ça que la
phrase il y a pas de sens c'est on est
on n'est pas chez les tuches mais on
n'est pas loin de si tu as la frite tu
as la patate quoi et si tu as la patate
bah tu peux faire de la purée tu es
c'était assez rigolo de le voir un peu
sinincère à un endroit et perdre le fil
de son truc et du coup faire juste sa
conclusion la phrase d'avant n'a pas de
sens par rapport à la conclusion une
nation qui se connaît
elle-même qui se respecte qui s c'est
dur les plans larges comme ça moi je
peux pas faire grand-chose he et qui
aura une vraie ambition pour où elle va
et avec des espaces de contestation des
libertés individuelles des voies de
progrès des débats comme nous aimons en
avoir sur tous les sujets possibles et
là on a le petit sourire de satisfaction
de la fin de la tirade c'est c'est c'est
tout cette espèce de monologue où
finalement quand même il était un peu en
dehors de son rôle donc un peu plus
sincère dans les attitudes et et en
train de s'écouter parler en parlant aux
autres he il jouait à l'orateur a priori
satisfait de sa de sa prestation quand
on voit cette attitude là ah ben voilà
le le voilà qui conclut et qui lui fait
naître ce vrai sourire là pour le coup
avec les ridules sur les yeux et cetera
là on est sur une grosse joie on touche
quasiment au bout de cette analyse non
verbale et quand même un petit peu
verbale par moment mais c'est pas de ma
faute il y avait trop de plans large
trop de plans avec la grue trop de plans
sur le public c'était trop loin je je
pouvais pas en faire autrement j'espère
que ça vous a stimulez vous aussi vos
réflexions alors je sais aussi qu'il y
en a qui disent oui il fait des analyses
pour faire des vues et pour faire sa
promo pour son spectacle oui aussi ça
fait partie des objectifs que vous
sachiez que je suis en spectacle dans ma
vie donc je vous le dis je suis entourné
avec mon spectacle de mentalisme
d'humour et de science qui s'appelle
archétype c'est la dernière version de
de ce spectacle la troisième celle qu'on
a lancé c'est début 2024 vous avez
toutes les villes qui s'affichent
regardez vous avez même une carte je
vais un petit peu partout il va aussi y
avoir la Polynésie la Nouvelle Calédonie
la Belgique la Suisse le Luxembourg le
Québec c'est en pour pararler je vous
mets un lien sur tout ça dans la
description à très bientôt dans la vraie
vie ou sur internet Ciao